When my son was born,
my daughter was about year and a half
old and you can get pretty intense
sibling rivalry with,
with kids aren't separated by three
years,
doesn't mean you should separate them by
three years,
but,
but because the older kid is still
pretty dependent,
so you got to watch that.
So the first thing we did was we talked
to her about the new baby that was
coming and we told her that that was
going to be her baby,
you know,
as well as our baby.
That's your baby.
And then we taught her to get a hug and
we had her act that out.
It's like okay,
when when the new baby comes,
there's going to be times when your mom
was preoccupied.
You got to say it in a way,
a three year old,
one and a half year old,
something like that was one and a half
can understand and that means acting it
out in playing.
Right?
Like pretend play.
But the message was there'll be times
when you're going to feel lonesome and
you have to come and get a hug.
Well,
so then we'd have for practices like
let's play a game,
pretend you're like,
okay,
now come and get a hug.
It's like,
okay.
She'd get a hug.
This is better than the knife game.
I think it's better.
It's better.
It's better than the knife gate.
Well in so okay,
so far.
And then we had our new,
our son and we helped Mckayla,
my daughter figure out how to take care
of him and you know,
when he wasn't in a half year old can
actually take care of the baby.
They can watch the baby and the baby
cries.
They can come and tug on you,
you know,
say the baby needs,
whatever the baby needs.
And so then,
well then there's the older child also
gets a set of privileges because of
that.
It's like,
well,
you're older,
you don't get to be an infant anymore.
That's kind of socks because mums with
you all the time,
it's like,
what do you get in exchange?
You get some more freedom.
You get some more status,
you get some more power.
It's like it's a good trade off.
That's why you want to grow.
That's fine.
You want to become an adult.
You don't want to steal that from
people.
It's still there.
It's that sense.
That's the witch in Hansel and Gretel
who fattens up the kids and eats them.
It's like compared to my layer,
the Latin gingerbread and candy,
you wouldn't have to do anything.
I'll take care of you.
It's like,
yeah,
run away from that person.